today we have harry zhang co-founder of
lob lob makes api's for companies to
send letters and postcards so kevin has
a question for you I'm trying to think
back to when you guys applied to YC you
you didn't have almost anything like I
would say it was fairly embarrassing yes
you could say that I mean honestly we
were scrambling weeks before the
interview they try to come up with
something that we thought was worthwhile
for demoing but I think the important
thing when you're starting you know a
company and for us is thinking about the
problem that you're working on Versalles
like having a bunch of stuff and I think
for us like we had done sort of the due
diligence beforehand we talked to a lot
of customers we had a good sense for
what the core problems are but we didn't
have like the exact product just yet
what was that MVP when you guys applied
to I say at the time you know I think
back and it's pretty funny just thinking
about this we literally had an API to
took whatever you put into it and spit
it right out to you and that's that was
our MVP and we were secretly hoping it
just mirrored the response back yeah
it's just merely response back and we
were just sort of hoping that we
wouldn't have to demo because honestly
we hadn't built a lot of product yet we
didn't know what we wanted to build and
you know we've always operated from the
valve he's like we want customers to pay
us for something before we actually go
and do it what's interesting to me as
someone who's focusing on design and
interfaces at YC is that I kind of
really love API companies because like I
think a lot of people think of it as
like oh it has no sort of interface but
to me the interfaces is just
documentation it's like very pure and so
I'm always interested in when I look at
an API a company is looking at oh what
are they doing here to say this is how
we want to both community around this
because like what they're trying to
build out is that this is something that
people who build stuff want to use and
so what are the ways they're going to
communicate that this will allow them to
do something sort of cool or solve a
problem etc and I feel like you learn a
lot about people's thought processes and
also how good someone is as an engineer
programmer by like how thoughtful that
documentation is I think stripe is a
classic example of this but for you guys
I remember
it's like you had the basics down but it
was clear that you guys knew enough to
be considered to anyone that would want
him to be using it even if it was their
first time ever writing any API call
yeah yeah that's that for me right I
mean I think documentation to this day
is still like the number one thing and
with ink we take a point in pride and
making sure that our documentation is
something that every single developers
want to use and I see is friction like
when your core product is an API
you better have like the best
documentation on the planet and so what
was the insight you guys had early on
that made you convinced that you wanted
to follow this path yeah that's a good
question so I actually started from like
the problem and it started from my time
at Microsoft so immediately I did not
think I was gonna end up in a business
that's focused on mail nor did I think
that a job at Microsoft at a company
that's 100% tech based one of the main
things I was gonna be working on was
actually a direct mail campaign so sort
of like how we initially got started the
problem and actually started from a
place of complaining I was driving back
from a ski trip with my co-founder Lior
and I was complaining to him about this
project that I was working on at
Microsoft and essentially what we were
doing is we had come up with the system
for sending out these like very custom
training materials and invites like a
webinar online but for a number of
different reasons we weren't allowed to
do that using email and telesales was
too expensive so the thing I was doing
was actually building a direct mail
program that was one of the most
effective things that we've done to date
and honestly it was a little out of you
know we didn't have any other options
but when it worked really well
I got a huge budget and was asked to
sort of scale across a much bigger set
of customers and different use cases and
more products and I thought that was
gonna be something that was easy
but it turned out to be the bane of my
existence for like the following three
months in the early days like for YC
what did the API do oh yeah
the API just went into a database that
you know literally I start off using my
inkjet printer
you know we printed everything on my
home printer out of my apartment
there hit a point where we were watching
TV and stuffing like we had a sembly
line of like letters that we were
stuffing ourselves and it sort of at
that point we're like maybe we should go
get a printer to help us with this
problem what makes you feel confident
you could just go try to sell to a
company or get someone to program
against that even though it was like
connected to like your injector printer
well like what gave you the confidence
is like I'll go in here and sell someone
on this fake magic yeah that's I guess
like for us it was more just like a
belief that this was like a real problem
for people so when we told them about
the problem that we're solving it really
resonated with the customers that we
were talking to and I remember like our
very first customer it's this guys named
William way last use-case I'd expect for
mail he found us on our hacker news
launch and he sent me a note saying hey
like I want to use your guys's lighter
product and can we chat I said okay well
you know like tell me a little bit more
about your business and sixteen year old
kid awesome I looked him up I was like
very little information online but he
actually ran one of the largest Team
Fortress 2 stores online and if you
don't know what - Fortress 2 is do you
know what that is one my favorite games
perfect so one of the things that people
like to do is they buy digital items
online right and that's like a regular
thing because people don't want to go
through all this time to like you know
find like the right weapon or whatever
that might look like so he did one of
the largest Team Fortress or shoes
online and I was still super confused
I'm like why are you talking to me and
just didn't know but it turns out he had
a problem which was every single time
people would buy his items online he'd
deliver it and give him like it you know
the item online but he had no proof that
he actually gave them at his items so
what you had was a ridiculously high
rate of fraud which was people would
charge back and he will lose every
single dispute because he couldn't show
that he actually sent anything so his
solution to this problem was I'm also
just going to send him a letter in the
mail with the coat and that serve that
has proof but he had to do that himself
and he hated that mmm that's something
that we would have never like thought of
out of the gate but I think it goes to
show right like you can always hang with
his product but not always
how'd he find you so he found us like
online on Hacker News a Jamaican show HN
type thing that's great you did a show
HN I think that's where I might still be
around somewhere
but that's sort of how you found us
right and we basically said we have an
API for sending letters and he was like
I have I have a problem like can you
guys help me with this and then once you
got past having 16 year olds as clients
how do you how did you get the first
like really top tier big client yeah I
think you know for us that top tier
clients it's a big insurance company
that's currently in New York I would say
they're pretty tech for it can't tell
you the name of that company but one of
the things that's exciting that we found
them was they had a problem and that
they didn't have compliance and security
around they're assisting printers so
this isn't the midst of like me as a
sales rep literally sending like
hundreds and thousands of emails to
potential companies that thought could
be a fit and this one got a response
back you know from the CEO he asked a
few sort of qualifying questions and
punted me to you know the guy was
actually in charge using now they're a
VP of data and they had a problem that
their printer they didn't have
confidence they're printing you what
like HIPAA was they didn't know what a
BA was and they were essentially
reevaluating with technology they were
using to work for print shop and that's
sort of where we entered and ultimately
that become became one of our first
major like real customers and they're
still client with us today it's just a
cold email you sent out it was just a
cold email how long would here's here's
a question can you remember like what
was in that cold email like was it super
short was it super long did you was it
personalized etc it was definitely
personalized you know I I had a good
idea of what type of mail that could be
potentially sending and it was a
shortcrust email like this is what we do
here's how we're different and I think
we can help you if your current problem
in these three ways right I think the
key things in a cold email you really
want to hit on like did you guys I was
gonna say like where you clued in on the
HIPAA or not I did not know I was having
a problem at that company I did we
didn't know what like HIPAA was and this
was sensitive information but like we
didn't know that that that they were
looking mm-hmm so we got a little it was
a little bit luck okay they were looking
we didn't know about it we knew that
they were sort of within the space that
we're looking for but honestly in the
early days not everyone's gonna be able
to find you
and what's important especially in you
know our business as like a you
b2b SAS businesses you got to find the
customers that believe in the method and
the methodology and how you're building
the product not just what you serve
today but also the vision of what your
product could become and that's where we
found a lot of alignment you know with
this company because they understood
exactly why building it as an API is
valuable they're super technology
forward and while we didn't have every
single capability and you did we could
cover the majority of what they want and
they knew that we would be able to scale
with them as well mmm
and so what once you got there how did
you start expanding that like the other
top tier clients because it's all just
cold email like the these are big
contracts I imagine yeah these are
definitely big contracts so you know
today our contracts are everything from
light you know on a small sigh for our
main markets like 30,000 a year just to
use
LOB's api and we sell contracts up to
like millions of year as well so there's
a big range but I think for us it
there's a couple things it's a sort of a
chicken-egg problem and that like you
need a lighthouse customer to get other
big customers so giving them the first
one is always the hardest and that's a
combination it's just like combination
of law hard work and really
understanding like your problem space
and what you're solving once you've done
that and you've successfully done that
for a customer it's much easier to take
that exact same story to a similar
customer and help them realize that
value and you know by that point you
should also understand sort of the
language of the customer you know in
their industry what do they care about
what are the key problems that they have
and when you have that insight it makes
you much more credible as a potential
vendor right how much time do you guys
spend researching before you like we
chat to let's say you have one company
you're like I really want to have their
business what's the prep work that you
start doing who do you start contacting
how long does it sort of take yeah I
mean there's a fair amount of prep work
so you know for us it's it's starts from
just mapping out the organization right
drawing a blueprint of like who are the
key stakeholders in the organs
especially for larger companies
decisions aren't made by just one
individual there are made am i different
folks and each different person may have
a slightly different motivation we have
work with our sales reps to figure out
what is that motivation for each of
those individual who are so they're the
key contacts and what's the message
that's going to resonate
them so we'll typically start by having
coal outreach these folks will also sort
of combine it with a lot of our
marketing tactics and that like they're
gonna start seeing law pop up everywhere
right and ideally you know if they're
not responsive to email will also look
at what conferences they're gonna be
attending so we can actually find these
folks in person
so really it's sort of like a
multi-pronged approach it's pretty rare
and you shouldn't have expectation just
like I you know I send like you know ten
emails I'm gonna get like eight
responses back that's that's not gonna
happen it's a grind but that's part of
your job is to like work your way
through that and figure out like who are
the counts are gonna work and over time
you're gonna get more and more accurate
about understanding and motivation what
resonates with people and like what
people care about and you may find that
like the person you thought was the
person who's gonna make decision might
actually be someone totally different
did you always knew know that this was
going to be an enterprise company that
this would be what you'd focus on or was
there like a lot of people will start an
API coming in with like anybody could
use this anybody should and so like how
did you know where to focus and actually
I'm kind of interested is like what is
this wit and ap I imagine most of it as
enterprise usage but how much is also
SMB how much is like consumers using it
yeah yeah absolutely so I'd say roughly
about you know 15% or so of our business
is still self-service customers today so
it's a meaningful share of our revenue
and that fluctuates based on how much
our big customers do but like there's a
healthy self-service segment of folks
that utilize our API and that's where we
started so for us like you know how we
ended up focusing at Enterprise is
really sort of evaluation of like our
market and it turns out like the market
that we're in today the top you know 20
players send such an enormous amount of
mail that if you really want to capture
the entire market you have to focus on
how you gonna win those top couple folks
and what we realize is one of the things
that's really nice about an API is that
like you can essentially give those same
capabilities to people who aren't
executing a tech type of volume so in
fact it's a focus for our business to
Sinese enterprise customers but we know
a lot of the features and functionality
that these guys have or are looking for
are also things that smaller customers
want but don't have access to because
operating at that scale capacity you set
an API enables them to get access to
that so you guys like graduated up to
enterprise that's right how long did
that take we were still working on it
now even today
so really it's been a six-year journey
for us I would say we signed our first
few true like enterprise accounts you
know just two years ago so it took us
almost four years ago yeah so there's a
while so one thing a lot of startups
don't get right is pricing so when you
guys were working your way up to
enterprise by the time you got that
first big client did you feel like you
had your pricing locked down because of
like if that was wrong it could have
multiplied in a bad way quickly yeah
definitely you know we're always
evaluating our pricing to make sure we
have the right model we actually made
some like a pretty big mistakes early on
as I came to the price and I think like
you guys have probably all heard the
typical mistakes right it's like hey you
know didn't price high enough like you
know we didn't started talking about
pricing too late for us it's the
structure of pricing we actually learned
a lot about and was a big motivating
factor in us changing our pricing model
a couple years ago so we started off
thinking very much like a traditional
male provider or even someone who sells
like reservist this isn't AWS
essentially you could buy lob and what
you were buying is you'd buy you know
hundred thousand letters over the course
a year you pay for the hundred thousand
letters you can use it whenever you want
super logical very easy to understand
and it worked for us for a while but the
problem we found was we went into larger
customers they don't look at not every
single budget is made equal so when you
were selling you know hundred thousand
letters they're gonna evaluate us
against a hundred thousand letters from
another drive mail provider and you know
our value is you know five cents of that
letter is going to law right that's the
value that we see in our technology but
the problem is when you're talking to
customers who are used to pricing in a
specific methodology they're comparing
us to like why are you five five cents
marks months of everybody else and
they're starting to do the math like how
many more responses do I have to get
what's the higher conversion that I need
to see a result but in reality it's two
different investments right there making
a technology investment and the
technology that we're providing them
they're buying the male piece so one of
the big changes that we made that was
really successful in helping shift the
conversations to the right level of our
customers was actually creating what we
call like a platform fee so essentially
now our customers pay us you know twenty
five thirty thousand dollars a year to
use law and they get access to you know
our de facto like mail pricing which is
now competitive if not lower than every
single they're offering so now we can
focus the conversation it's like how do
you value lobs technology is that worth
twenty-five to thirty thousand and
setting up being a conversation about
what is the cost of a mail piece and
what's the conversion that we're looking
for I think it's important differentiate
and associate the value that customers
see in your technology with what they
pay for versus something that could be a
commoditized you know product in the
market today
now was that pricing model only an
option given your maturity I think we
could have started that model the
reality is we just we just didn't know
people were gonna think that way so it's
hard to get everything right what helped
you shift to that well we kept getting
feedback from customers right and we
could tell that the way that they were
modeling us was they would be trying to
figure examples to apples comparison
yeah listen it wasn't a big deal apples
comparison that is out there right and
the part that was challenging just like
they were totally okay of like paying
with like another agency to help manage
their mail sense right but that's not
pulling out of the same budget and
essentially part of what we offer is
like we're doing that forward them but
they were looking at our mail piece
price and comparing it to another mail
piece price but in reality it's the mail
piece price plus whatever they're paying
this other agency to manage it for them
but those are coming out to different
budgets right so for us we had this
realization when we started talking to
companies and they kept trying to sort
of ask like oh well why is it more
expensive when really the reason why is
more expensive is because we're doing
more things for them right and that's
very logical but help them understand
you know model that are used to we had
adapt to what they've already seen in
the market one of the things that's been
interesting to me as a trend is that
like
software wanting to be a commodity and
the value and price of it getting lower
and lower and then you know API
companies like sit at the very bottom
there like fundamental like
infrastructure for services and so you
know this is probably related but how do
you think about that as a business like
do you guys set out to be like okay
we're we're gonna look here to compete
on price or on sort of a value and then
how can value work in an infrastructure
sort of commodities like business yeah
yeah I'm and I think it's different for
every single commodity right so you know
while you might be able to compare like
email or SMS I think those are priced
differently in didn't you know lob for
us I think what we found is we wanted to
be cost competitive if not the best
price to market for the actual cost of
mail which we see is a relatively
commoditized product right you can go to
any number of commercial printers and
they can produce the mail for you so
really like what's different about
buying software through lob is that
you're getting access to our entire API
and all the Associated offerings that
come with our platform by sending email
through law so we want to differentiate
like what is it that customers paying we
want them to know that they're getting
the best price in a market for something
that they see as a commodity which is
the cost of the actual mail piece but we
want them to pay us the value that they
saw and using our software to send mail
so that's sort of why we made this split
and having a platform fee as well as
like a per piece price how does that
adjust your sort of product roadmap that
like have these technology differences
that makes you different from like just
a printer who can say like hey I can do
that digital printing yeah that's a good
question so I think for us it goes down
to a conversation like how much are
these like features worth to our
customers right and I think over time we
built different layers like different
sort of offerings like nimbarka and
enterprise offering we realized that
customers would be willing to pay more
for specific features what are some
examples so a good example this is like
you know HIPAA one of the key
considerations for companies are more
regulated spaces that they need to have
a
but compliant offering now like it's
more expensive for us to have like a
HIPAA compliant offering but we also
realize that one of the key
considerations when companies are
looking at you know printers is can they
meet these requirements so we actually
charge more for those customers because
it costs us more and also because
there's less offerings that are able to
do something like that programmatically
right now they're gonna manage their
customer information in a secure fashion
both in terms of how they Tran
transitioning the information to you and
transferring it to you as well as like
you know being stored in our system and
this is like you know people's names and
addresses this is very sensitive
information for a lot of companies and
it's something that they value very
highly we had customers that would be
like we'll pay you if you guys can do X
for us and that's when you really know
you're onto a feature that's really
important because they can actually
quantify the value that that's worth to
them and it makes it easier for us to
understand and prioritize our product
roadmap because we know what customers
are willing to pay for not just like you
know hey can they achieve a slightly
higher conversion of hip mothering now
we know that like they're gonna pay us
an extra ten thousand it's worth it's
done because that's what they see and so
what are the other trades that you've
made in the context of like fulfilling
the desires of these enterprise
customers when you realize oh maybe they
don't care about this for example like
more vertical integration type stuff
yeah so I think some examples of this is
like we realized that the execution
component like being able to track your
mail and having sort of a platform
offering being available through API
that was really important because a lot
of companies actually are especially
larger folks they're working with
agencies that have helped them with a
lot of the you know segmentation to
actual management of the campaign the
design of the mail pieces you know these
are things that we've thought about
building products around make it easier
for people to build beautiful mail
pieces but what we found is like most
people already have that in enterprise
they're already ready to go their
problems are not around you know the
need for designing a better mail piece
they have a full-service creative agency
that has like 16 different campaigns and
I've already thought that through so
they already have it right so there's a
good example for you how many employees
do you guys have at well how big are you
guys yeah we're we're we've been hiring
a lot this year so we're just shy of 70
right now just 70 and then don't take
offense but for an API company I met
it's difficult to recruit people here
and so like what do you guys have to do
and what have you sort of figured out
that that helps you sort of like compete
against everyone else out here in Yasko
I mean I can tell you mail is not
exactly the most sexy thing in the world
certainly not you know a I love these
non sexy users especially ones that make
money yeah and so to me it's like that's
probably a good leg up but I'm just
wondering like for you guys if you're
looking for that like yeah top engineer
to come on and make a difference yeah
like how do you inspire them with the
mission like this good question
so a couple things that we think about
the first thing you need to do is
understand the motivations for each
individual that you're trying to hire
everyone's gonna care about something
sounds a lot like your sales yeah but
there's but it's true right you have to
realize like what is it that people want
to join a company for and you need to
identify the folks that are good fit for
where we're really strong so for us if
you go and you ask like why some of the
folks join law I think the majorities
folks would tell you it's it's around
our culture right that and that's the
reason that they got inspired to join so
the mission is certainly important and I
think we spend a lot of time I'm talking
not just about what we do today but like
what is that we want to achieve but
ultimately I think one of the key
consideration is like what's it going to
be like to actually work out law how can
am I gonna be happy there
and that's a huge motivating factor for
a lot of people so we spend a lot of
time internally thinking about you know
our culture how do we sort of like find
the right folks that map into the
culture that we have how do we sort of
like give engineers and give potential
candidates a sense for what your culture
is like and we do that through writing
blogs we do that through you know having
people come on-site beforehand to get a
sense of what it's like to be there and
we try to make sure that throughout sort
of like our activities we're tying
together our core values and giving
people a good representation of what
it's like to work at law and so also
part of this is the comp and so before
we start recording you talked about
options versus rsu's yeah what's your
opinion on that yeah so you know I think
they're both good instruments do you
mind helping for those people who might
yeah what is the difference between like
an RSU and yeah option absolutely so one
of the things Connelly misunderstood is
like equity compensation
so RS use and options they're both
different forms of equity that company
can offer you in a company the main
difference that we see options
essentially you've to purchase so
there's a strike prices associated for
options so as an employee you have to
make a decision at some point in the
company's lifecycle that you want to
spend you know your own money to
purchase shares of the company and
that's why you've essentially one option
is it's the right to purchase shares at
this particular price point but the
reality is you know you're gonna pay
some relatively significant amount of
money potentially in order to acquire
those shares and we've heard like people
taking out loans to do this like there's
companies designed to help people do
this so it's not an insignificant amount
of money RS use are a little bit
different RS use is actually a stock
grant so you know there's actual value
to artists you that you're receiving and
you're not paying for the right to the
RS you you're actually being granted
that RS you so for us you know at LOB we
actually decided and I think it's a
little non-traditional that we built
sort of like a unique RSU instrument
that we think is sort of like the best
of both worlds right and essentially the
motivations where we want company to be
people to be invested in a company in
the long term we want design equity
compensation that didn't feel like a
risk to the employee the whole entire
reason why you want equity in a company
is you want a share in the upside you
want to feel like you're a part owner
the company but if you have to like
spend an enormous on money without
knowing what the outcome of the company
is going to be in advance which you
can't predict that puts you in this like
weird scenario where you like you want
to buy your shares but you're not sure
if you wanted and we felt like that was
a really tough position to be in as a
potential candidate so we design artists
use in a way so that you know our
employees actually rsu's when you join
law so what that means is you don't have
to make that consideration of like you
know should I spend the money to buy my
options when should I exercise that and
there's obviously some differences there
right like I think the major difference
is like when you get tax but we always
looked at it as you know you don't get
taxed and rsu's until there's actual a
liquidity event in this scenario because
we don't physically we don't actually
grant you the Rs you and tell you there
is liquidity event so therefore you know
you out
is at the time of which you receive
money right rsu's and i think you know
what we found is that you know
especially employees you understand cui
competition that's something that's
really attractive to them and when we
think about wanting people be here for
30 years we don't want people to stay
for the wrong reasons of like oh I don't
have the money exercise my options I'm
gonna stay I wanted to stay because they
enjoy the people that work with they
enjoy what we're working on are inspired
thumbs up we have but we still want to
give them a share and actually being an
owner in the company mmm and how do you
handle vesting so sales team best thing
specially do a one-year cliff and we
essentially you know vest monthly
thereafter so it's the same as like an
option in that sense one thing we do we
also reserve like retention grants for
people's so at our two and a half year
mark and every year thereafter we
continue to give people opportunity to
gain additional equity in the company
and our thought is like the longer you
stay at the company the more equity you
should be able to acquire there
shouldn't be a point where you ever stop
earning equity in the company mmm so
what what kind of mistakes did you guys
make when it came to like closing your
first like big sales yeah so I actually
think there's a valuable lesson we
learned during our early YC days in that
like when you're selling your product
you're oftentimes selling something that
you might not have just yet but I also
think it's really important you have to
actually get alignment with your
customer and be upfront about like what
you do what you can do today what you
might be able to do if you share an also
agree on like a timeline of what that
looks like
get it in writing and have that sort of
be part of the close of the deal where
we weren't wrong and I sort of laughed
because we built what I thought was a
freaking awesome product back in a day
we actually had a mugs API this is in
our like demo day slot its coffee mugs
yeah coffee mugs there's a point where
we thought it was a brilliant idea to be
able to print coffee mugs on demand
through our API we wanted to be able to
print on anything and how this happens
we had a customer who came to us and
told us that they had this use case for
coffee mugs and it was like a big number
a really big number for us and you know
when you're small every single you know
deal looks super valuable and we're like
this is awesome these are so cool the
two coffee mugs
and we built the product so we told the
customer we can definitely do for you
you know we'll have free choice and we
scramble and we hustle super hot we
built a fully functioning mugs API
product but we didn't sign any paperwork
this customer so we built this whole
entire thing we spent two weeks of
valuable engineering time we met two
customer mr. customer we have the mugs
API here's how you use it and he was
like awesome like we'll get right on it
he went dark he stopped responding I was
super disappointed to this date we sold
two mugs mugs API - one of them went to
another YC partner actually Dalton he
was working on an app that net and I
convinced him that like he should
definitely do mugs as well and I think
he put in like one order for it and it
worked
he's like this was awesome we killed the
product a little bit shortly after but I
think it was a really valuable lesson
and that like you always want to be
selling a little bit ahead of where you
are but you also want to align up the
customer like what you actually haven't
don't have and that actually helped us
close you know one of our biggest
customers today in booking comm so you
know essentially how this opportunity
came about is they were already a
customer of law using our address
verification API and they had sort of
this moment in time with gdpr where they
started reevaluating all their vendors
for print and we sort of got roped into
consideration one of the key things that
was really important to them was
actually like having operations in
Europe they were familiar with our API
in the US they knew it worked really
well but like they're a global company
and of course like they want to know
what our long-term plan is to support
Europe and eventually Asia so you know
part of the negotiation as we're working
through this big deal its customers that
we need to align with them on a timeline
and how we were gonna get Europe up and
running for them so for us that's
originating you know letters and
postcards and our other mail offerings
in Europe and that was sort of tricky
but I think we had learned some valuable
lessons in that like we weren't gonna
just go and build all of Europe and
scramble for potentially months at a
time but we also weren't going to tell a
customer something we didn't have either
so we were pretty upfront about them
about what our capabilities look like
you know the timeline of which you're
going to roll
and we actually agrees to all these
things at during our negotiation so what
it really helped is like our customer
actually want to help us get things
going faster right they're like we want
you guys get up and running you're up
like right now and you know we could
actually ask for their help in building
exactly what is that why and now it's
sort of like a partnership rather than
like hey we've oversold something it's
more about how can we work with our
customer to achieve the results that we
both want to get to and I think that's
really important especially as you're
talking about larger enterprise deals
you're not always gonna have everything
but really sort of structuring and not
over selling it but also setting the
right expectation of customers it's
difficult to navigate that sometimes but
we found as a policies better to be you
know upfront honest about what you can
and can't do and actually you know if
the customer really wants to work with
you they're gonna find a way to make it
work with you and that's the best
position to be in mm-hmm
are there other examples where you get a
potentially incredibly high value kind
of like enterprise scale client and they
want something that you don't do do you
now like kind of fish around see if
anyone else is interested in the Muggs
API before you follow through with it
yeah definitely so like I think a common
example this is we're always evaluating
mail format so what I mean by that is
like you know you get different types of
letters all shapes and sizes we don't
support every single different yeah mail
offering today but we have a list of
like what company people have been
asking for and what we found is for us
is a little bit of a chicken and egg
problem we don't want to start with like
a really small volume customer because
it makes it difficult for us
operationally but same time it's like we
also know that this is a product people
are interested in they want to see proof
points so what we found is you know we
have a list of these mail for meditation
we're constantly evaluating when we talk
to potential customers we know here's a
list that we would potentially be
willing to consider so they can agree on
a commitment level of like what they're
gonna send and you know then we're
willing to entertain some of those areas
and that's actually helped we build some
products in the past before you know we
recently just launched I think you know
earlier this week certified mail
receipts we knew that when we launched
certified mail this is for William way
if you guys remember he needed a
certified mail we launched certified
mail but he didn't need certified mail
tracking
because he didn't really care like when
it received you just care that he had a
proof point mm-hmm but we knew that that
was something that we could potentially
do we chose not to do an early age
because we didn't have like customers to
willing to do that on mass so you know
we were able to we got a few customers
that were really interested in certified
mail but felt like when you were missing
this one little thing in you know mail
receipts and we had that sort of like
plan and we had thought about it and
finally we had the right customer who
come before willing to make that
commitment level we're already familiar
for a product we actually went and built
it and we just launched it that this
week Congrats so the way that you pad
works is like you guys provide this
technology layer and you connect to all
like a network of all these printers
that's correct
all around the world that's correct so
what I'm kind of curious about is like
you've seen this trend as firstly as
companies get larger and larger where
they get more vertically integrated well
Dale like want to do every step of the
process so they can own it in terms of
quality but also like an R&D and cetera
and I'm kind of curious do you feel like
is that a thing that you guys will
eventually do or if not why not
so for example it's just like basically
you buy a printer or you like own some
printing facilities and be like okay
great because like this whole like
flexibility and mail format etc like
part of the reason that you have to be
cautious about what you go into is
because you have to go and spend time to
find the right partners booth out the
integration and then sort of make it
work and so I'm just kind of curious
about like is there a point in the
future where lob like like owns owns
like a giant printer yeah I mean we
don't have that in the plan today is the
short answer
right certainly if there's a huge need
we'd consider it but you know the
motivation for us is like we see mail SS
somewhat commoditized product we also
know that like it's a huge industry for
a reason there are hundreds of thousands
of printers that are out there but they
all specialize in like slightly
different things so you know for us to
be good at what we do we can't try to do
everything at once it would actually be
really difficult and super Kappa Lee a
capital intensive for us to buy all of
the necessary hardware and like what if
our customers need to change we won
flexibility and part of having sort of a
network of folks enable us to have the
flexibility I remember in our very early
days at lob we are still this is pre lob
or pre YC application one of the things
we want to do is we sort of just want to
get our own printer real like hey it'd
be nice if we could just like do it
ourselves like why do we need like real
fine somebody else that's just like
another place for something to go wrong
because you're looking at all these
printers and probably like these guys
are in the Stone Age like like we should
be replacing them yep that's that's
exactly right
so we called up an HP Indigo vendor so
if you guys don't know HP Indigo czar
like the commercial print standard
everyone you re in printers yet it's
like this is what you want trust me so
we figured a satin honestly we didn't
know too much about like the print world
at the time so we called the sales rep I
think the first time for him should have
been like it was weird that meet we're
meeting in a Starbucks we met this guy
Starbucks we didn't have a company to
have a product at time we're like we're
just saying get this printer because
like we can do it better so we start
asking them all the right questions like
who like what's like you know how we're
gonna do inserter like what are the
different formatting options like we
cover everything and this guy's feeling
really good about this we're like yeah
this guy's really smart he knows exactly
why we're definitely get this so my
co-founder loves negotiates like so like
how much like would this cost and he
sort of taken aback
he's like start immediately talking
about like they're releasing options and
in my head I'm like I don't want to
lease this I just want to buy it like
we're about to go get some money and
we're gonna raise capital we're gonna go
buy this and do it so we sort of like
you know corner him a little bit like I
like how much it cost like offer us a
better price if we just buy outright and
I think I don't remember the exact
number but it was something like over a
million dollars and I sort of looked at
lira I was like dude we're not doing
that like no chance we're gonna buy that
printer but I think you know you know
thinking about where we are today like
you know maybe we do want to buy that
printer but like there's it immediately
creates a ton of complexity in our
business absolutely and that's the thing
I'm just curious about as I go Amazon
could have continued using 3pl services
but at some point they realize like we
need to own and build our own warehouses
to build up a certain efficiency like we
have a vision
the future that requires us to own that
technology inside and so I'm just
curious like you know what at what point
do you guys start to be like oh you know
what we're we're being held back by our
partners yeah yeah that's a good
question so we haven't felt that way and
our partners have been like incredible
partners and honestly they're experts at
print they are they know so much more we
did down to like the color calibration
that we should be using on all of our
printers I think the places we want to
think about it is if it could give us a
competitive advantage if we're able to
offer something by owning the print
infrastructure that will give us the
ability to do something nobody else can
but I think that's like complex for us
right that would be like hey we have a
you know we have a awesome hardware
printing engineer who thought of a
completely new way to do print and we're
gonna go compete with like HP's imaging
division and we decided we can offer
something that like nobody else has done
we can like do this new you know Oh
someone came out on a marquee with like
a brand new type of printer that can do
offset printing like that like yeah if
we good yeah someone could do offset
printing using like digital methodology
at a price point that was like not
achievable to pass I would be interested
in talking to you anybody who's starting
that company by the way the Tesla cool
so you you guys are now six years old
and six years coming up soon how have
you had to change as a founder and a
manager over those years yeah it's a
good question
I think the first thing and I'm still
getting comfortable that now is
understanding that like your role as a
founder is gonna constantly keep
changing for some reason in the early
days you know just like hey I'll just
like constantly be building cool product
then I found a place where we needed
somebody to go do sales so I led the
sales team for a number of years and
then all of a sudden we were doing okay
on sales but we didn't have any lead so
I started working on marketing and I
think what I found is that my roles then
they continue to change and that's
something like you have to get
comfortable with us like a founder is
that your role is gonna change and
that's okay because what that's
essentially saying is that you guys have
gotten good enough that you can hire
somebody else
do that and I think that's a you know
expectation everyone should have when
you go into business that like you
should be comfortable of every aspect
you know I think a lot of people like
think that they can just just build
product forever
everyone should talk to customers
everyone should be going and trying to
do sales in the early days because if
you as a founder in a company can't sell
the product nobody else is gonna be able
to either yeah that's a great piece of
advice all right thanks man thanks for
coming in yeah absolutely thanks for the
time guys thanks Harry
you